[Music]
let's go to uh emmy in nashville what's
up emmy
hi dr john how are you i was man
i'm doing fantastic and i'm not very
good at this radio thing do you have
tick-tock
i don't i don't really have social media
so
oh i think i need to call your show
cause i need help
need help okay so what's up what's going
on
um so my main question is how do i get
out of my own way so i need so i can
achieve my professional and personal
goals
um so i'll stop there and then um i
don't know if you want to stop me or
yeah tell me more tell me more
okay so
i have to take certain certifications um
for my job so i'll start with the job
and then i'll go to the personal side
so for my job i've had certifications
and up until this point
they've gone really really well but i've
hit a roadblock
and i would say that for the last couple
of years i've been taking these
certifications i have a habit of
starting many fires for lack of a better
term so that way i can give myself this
like emotional boost so that way like oh
well i fixed my problem and then like i
move on i do well on the certification i
move on um but now it's getting to the
point where it's my last certification
this is the end and i just can't seem to
pass it
so it's not necessarily that i don't
know the material it's just these mini
fires are no longer helping me
um in a lot of the different
like anger or fear motivators that i
used to have that would really focus in
on
my work are now just being
distractionary
and it's just it's really messing me up
and
i'm starting to have like physical
ramifications and so like now i get like
physically sick every time i go to these
certifications
um and so it's just getting really out
of hand and i need to figure out better
ways of handling this stress or getting
myself over this uh adventure awesome um
one thanks for sharing that
uh that's
a tough sled in there um
i'm assuming that you don't want to do
you mind telling me what what
certification you're looking for or give
me a general is it tax is it healthcare
is it something like what's what's the
general field
uh data science so it's a lot of like
computer programming and just like
finance content okay and so let's say
you pass your exam tomorrow what do you
go do
next
uh
for the industry that's pretty much it
like i get a fancy letter um and that's
pretty much it um it's it's technically
just to prove that like i am capable of
doing something
um and like i do every day so it's
obviously not necessary but it does
translate to um possible promotions in
the future
okay
um tell me about your life
um i would say that i'm kind of high
strong
you don't stop at emmy who you don't say
um and
i have to say like in my personal life
um
i'm very
oriented when it comes to goals
so i'm very good at getting from point a
to point b
with the exception of point b meaning
what i actually want to do um so
for example say i want to start dating
and stuff like that and then i like meet
someone i like and then i get
self-conscious i gain 40 pounds and then
i stopped talking to them because i feel
uncomfortable with myself gotcha um and
then i lose the weight again i finally
feel good about myself and then it
happens all over again tell me about
growing up talking about your folks
oh no they're they're great um really
low key we're really close and stuff
like that um very supportive family
um
how long have you how long has have you
struggled with this
this is something that's been around for
a long time right
yeah i would say that it
got worse when i left college i don't
know if like actually having
responsibility like true real
responsibility ramification just kind of
slapped me in the face
but i would say that probably since i
was in like elementary school middle
school i've always had issues
um with
confidence with um
kind of feeling great about myself and
not self-sabotaging when you say great
about yourself are you talking about
appearance are you talking about people
loving you talking about
people
you you feeling like they were in your
corner
um yeah i would definitely say outside
my family i've never really felt like i
can
trust what people think of me
um and i kind of
in my year of reflection i think it's
just like i'm
putting my own self-feelings onto them
and so if i'm feeling uncomfortable with
myself i'm interpreting as them being
uncomfortable with me
um and i just i listen to a lot of
distraction and noise and even though
like i have my family in my corners i'm
like no no no like
you're fine like this is not an issue
like stop listening to other people
i just get distracted
and i get self-conscious and
i listen to the wrong people um and then
it really wrecks havoc on my confidence
and myself
who told you
that you let me just say this okay i'm
gonna lob a grenade and you can
fall on it you can say that's stupid or
you can just throw it back at me is that
cool
how old are you
i'm 28. okay
um
it's not uncommon
when somebody is walking through what
you're struggling with okay
and they tell me that they have a great
relationship with their family
sometimes often that means that hey they
have a very safe defined role in that
family
and or that family has provided them
with care and comfort and all of the
answers to life's challenges
so what i mean by that is sometimes it
is a
mom would get upset and i know how to
take care of mom
or i know how to take care of dad or
there was an issue in their marriage a
long time ago and i was able to help
with the brothers and sisters whatever
like i have a very defined purpose there
or
um why don't you go ask your father your
dad will help you with that um you just
need to ask your mom oh i don't think
you should go to that school and that
was
a covert way of saying you are
absolutely not going to that school do
any of those ring a bell
um kind of the first i would say that i
didn't necessarily have a role
but it was definitely the family over an
individual and so
we work as a unit for the betterment of
this family and so
and what happened was always about the
family not any individual person
was always about the family about what
mom and dad wanted to do
or one of them in particular here here's
what i'm getting at i don't want to pull
your family apart here on just a short
phone call here's what i'm getting at
number one somebody told you a long time
ago and they demonstrated this over and
over and over again that emmy is to not
be trusted
emmy cannot rely on emmy emmy's got to
rely on us
and that's why i point back to
usually that starts with your parents
um
you oh honey that's just a stupid thing
you need to do it like this or you don't
look good in that shirt you need to
dress like this who
who would even wear that kind of
comments the second thing is is somehow
you translated that okay and again this
is as a child so it's not like a blame
thing this is just an either or
into i know how i can get people to
tell me i've got value to show me i've
got value and that's through achievement
and performance
and then you get out on your own
and you achieve one thing
and you still don't like who you see in
the mirror or more importantly you don't
trust yourself still and so you try to
achieve again and try to achieve again
and you keep pushing that line
and now you're at the end of a track
and your body knows you're not safe
so much so that it doesn't want you to
take that exam and it's going to make it
so physically sick so you don't
because
not passing an exam means not like it
would for me like oh man i screwed up or
i didn't study that hard or i'm just
dumb i didn't get it
it means to you
i am nothing
so that that's the general usual arc
tell me if i'm off somewhere
um so that's that's
the end goal is definitely kind of what
happened and i definitely developed the
mindset that
like if i don't achieve
um so yeah i would say that that's
very very accurate
uh my concern is
again that i haven't spent a lot of time
with you my concern is that your
safety inside of your family
has become enmeshment
their air is your air and your air is
their air
or if you were just to announce hey i'm
moving to south dakota i got a great
opportunity to be a programmer there i'm
28 i'm single i'm unattached so i'm
going to go live a crazy life i've got a
job in los angeles california i'm going
to live in a high-rise and i'm just
going to live it up for two years
that there would be a disruption to
their plans
is that accurate or not accurate
um
or they say
a little bit like my first reaction is
like oh no that's not true but i think
i'm also kind of seeing things through
rose-colored glasses because
i guess i would consider myself extreme
extreme ownership so if i'm in the room
and something happens it has to be my
fault if i wasn't there then it wouldn't
have happened
okay that's not extreme ownership
extreme ownership means when you are
leading a thing
you take responsibility for the outcome
it doesn't mean if you are abused you're
responsible for other people feeling
uncomfortable
extreme ownership is not
um hey you've been trained over the
course of 15 20 30 years that your voice
doesn't count or it's less than
everybody else's
and you need to go do this thing
and then you find yourself responsible
for everyone's feelings and thoughts
what you are as a peacekeeper not an
extreme owner
extreme ownership would say
i have this exam
i love sunday lunches i'm not going to a
sunday lunch until i pass this exam
because i really want this thing to be
done
and i want to do it really well
and i'm not going to care about my
feelings i'm going to create a very
strong
um schedule i'm gonna stick to it no
matter what
every day i'm just gonna get up and do
it i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it and
then if i fail i'm gonna take ownership
i did everything i could
and that i knew to do and i'm gonna go
get some coaching and i'm gonna go back
and do it again you see you see the
difference there yeah a peacekeeper
feels responsible for everybody else's
feelings because they were told your
feelings come last
that make sense
yeah and what i really i really want
emmy's feelings
to come first
do you even want to be a programmer
um
i mean
does it matter i'm good at painting
bedrooms i don't want to do that for a
living
i'm really good like i'm really talented
i'm good at mowing like i'm good at it i
can make a yard look really nice i do
not want to do that for a living
i can make a lot of money mowing i've
got a buddy that runs a lawn care
business he does well i don't do that
for a living what do you want to do
i have no
clue i'm being honest i have literally
no flow and unfortunately i guess i've
lost the art of
like
exploration like i kind of it's not an
art it's a desire
why
yeah who told you to quit exploring
somebody told you this stuff emmy
here's what he should say i
i hear a sense of adventure in you
and i hear a sense of resignation
that this is just the way this is going
to be
yeah and that's kind of what i'm trying
to get myself out is i recognize the
fact that
doing nothing or accepting like this is
it like it's not healthy and like i
there's so much
i want
to be
happy with
but it's just like i when i do achieve
it
like what does that mean like i'm still
stuck with myself yeah wherever you go
there you go you'll go with you right
yeah
and so it's making peace with who you
see in the mirror
and then deciding
hey is this what i want to do b what i
really want to do who do i want to be
and by the way i can keep plugging along
because i'm freaking emmy and i'm
awesome
i do good work i'm a good person a
character
and then it's making some really
hard but
um simple you know and you know the
difference there right like how do you
lose weight and exercise well that's
really simple but it's super hard to do
um i'm gonna make some really hard but
simple choices when it comes to
i've got an exam coming up so this is
i'm going to study like this even when i
don't want to
and i'm going to put the time and the
effort in because this is the last time
i'm going to take this exam
and i'm gonna eat healthy and i'm not
gonna self-sabotage on those moments
that i feel like i'm about to i'm gonna
have somebody that i reach out to and
then i call
and i'm making it sound really simple
and at the end of the day we overthink
it because it is i'm just gonna not do
those things
or i'm not going to take that last exam
it's not going to take it
i don't want to be doing this job i'm
tired of this job i i don't
you know what i mean it's like getting
to the end of uh
a mile 20 in the marathon
and be like why am i doing i don't want
to do this okay
if you
picture yourself i mean you just quit
you just stop the tests like you're like
dude i'm not am i doing this for a
certificate for an achievement that i
don't care that i even have for a job
that i don't even really want
like if you just stopped does that give
you peace or does that give you anxiety
um
i don't even know how i feel
apartment is like oh man like you were
so close just finish it just for the
fact that you say to yourself you're a
finisher you don't quit when things get
hard
um
but i've also i got into this role
because someone told me now that i think
about it i got into this role because
someone told me oh you won't be good at
it and i had to prove to them no no no
i'll be good at it i'll show you yeah
yeah yeah and so now i'm here so that
obviously the only person that needs to
watch it is me
well and
it sounds like you've outsourced
your feelings and thoughts to a degree
where
i mean i mean you're living like a life
of like almost instagram quotes
and you're judging yourself against them
like you're a 3d living and breathing
member of my community here in nashville
like you're on my team
you're one of us
like we may have like sat by each other
in a coffee shop for crying out loud you
know what i mean like
it's yes extreme ownership is good
that's not what's happening here
ownership first looks in the mirror and
says like i'm gonna own how i think and
how i feel and i'm gonna own my value
and it's high
like and i'm not gonna create an entire
trajectory of my life with a middle
finger in my rear view mirror because
man that's an exhausting way to live
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna send
you a couple of things okay
um
actually can i make a real bold
statement
yes yes and i want you when you hang up
the phone i want you to be like that
guy's an idiot okay if i'm wrong
um
the first thing i'm going to send you is
i'm going to send you a copy of my book
okay on your past change of future
here's why
i don't fully buy your story
um
i can count on maybe one hand and just a
few fingers the number of times that
someone's told me a similar situation to
what you're working through
that isn't carrying a lot of
garbage from their childhood
whether it was the best way i can find
um get mom and dad to
leave me alone or to
get their approval or to get their nod
of
um you're okay today was to get straight
a's or i need to get your attention by
going and do something bananas behavior
is a language and something about
your language like do you love me do you
love me do you love me as achievement
accomplishment accomplishment
achievement achievement i'll make sure
everybody's okay
i'm just gonna stay here in the nest i'm
never gonna jump out and fly
and so i'm gonna send you that you can
hang up the phone and be like dude my
family is perfect deloney quit trying to
dig into my past just everything's fine
um
i i would challenge you on that but
that's for another phone call so i'm
gonna send you that the second thing i'm
gonna send you is my buddy ken coleman
has a career assessment it's a it's a
thing you take online it's digital thing
and it helps
point you in the direction of what do
you actually want to do what do you
actually care about it's called a get
clear assessment i'm going to send you a
free one of those too i'm also going to
send you my buddy ken i'm going to say
the same guys ken's book paycheck to
purpose where you can sit down and go
okay i'm making a living i'm doing this
coding thing
what do i want to do i'm officially a
quarter of the way through
right no probably a third i'm a third of
the way through
and i am
i'm getting out of here like i'm i'm
going to go do something that i really
want to do i want to go be a part of
let's figure figure out what that is
when it comes to the exam i'm like you
you're this close i'd finish
but i think i would take the emotion and
the stuff and strip it away and say
i am i am emmy and i'm a good person and
i love myself and i love my life whether
i fail this test or not i'm gonna go
take this test i'm gonna pass this test
i'll move on with my day
and really take the drama out of it and
it sounds so simple and uh doing it it
is
it is i'm gonna create a structure and a
strategy and go get it done
thanks for calling me um
think there's a wide open space for you
to go running
wide open and this is one of those
moments where you can back up and just
change
everything